The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: Today's
lecture is one where--
it's a lecture I've
never given before.
And it's very much
related to the experiments
we are doing right now
in my research group.
And so basically, we
have a chirped pulse
of microwave radiation, which
is propagating through a sample.
It causes all of the
molecules in the sample
to be prepared in some way.
We call it polarized.
And this polarization
relaxes by what
we call free induction decay.
And they produce
a signal which--
so we have a pulse
of radiation that
propagates through the sample.
The two-level
systems in the sample
all get polarized, which
we'll talk about today.
And they radiate
that polarization.
And we collect it
in a detector here.
And so the two
important things are
this is a time
independent experiment,
and that we have a whole
bunch of molecules.
And they're interacting
with the radiation
in a way which is complicated.
Because this is not--
each one of them
has quantum states,
but all of the
particles in this sample
are somehow interacting
with the radiation field
in a way which is uncorrelated.
So we could say all
of these particles
are either bosons or fermions.
But we're not going
to symmeterize
or anti-symmeterize.
Each of these particles
is independent.
And we need a way of describing
the quantum mechanics
for an ensemble of
independent particles.
So it's a big step towards
useful quantum mechanics.
And I'm not going
to be able to finish
the lecture as I planned it.
So you should know
where I'm going.
And I'm going to be introducing
a lot of interesting concepts.
The first 2/3 of
lectures votes are typed.
And you could have seen them.
And the rest of them will
be typed later today.
This is based on material
in Mike Fayer's book, which
is referenced in your notes.
This book is really accessible.
It's not nearly
as elegant as some
of the other treatments of
interaction of radiation
with two-level systems.
Now I talked about
interaction of radiation
with two-level systems
in lecture number 19.
And this is a completely
different topic
from that, because
in that, we were
interested in many transitions.
Let me just say the
radiation field that interact
with the molecule is weak.
It interacts with
all the molecules,
and the theory is
for a weak pulse--
and the important point in
lecture 19 was resonance.
And so we made the
dipole approximation.
And each two-level system
is separately resonant
and is weakly interacted
with, and does something
to the radiation field.
Now here, we're
going to be talking
about a two-level
system, only two levels.
And the radiation
field is really strong,
or is as strong as you want.
And it does something
to the two-level system
which results in a signal.
And because the radiation
field is strong,
it's not just a matter of taking
two levels and mixing them.
The mixing coefficients
are not small.
It's not linear response.
The mixing is sinusoidal.
The stronger the
radiation field,
the mixing changes, and all
sorts of interesting things
happen.
So this is a much harder
problem than what was
discussed in lecture number 19.
And in order to
discuss it, I'm going
to use some important tricks
and refer to something
called the density matrix.
The first trick is we
have this equation which
can easily be derived.
And most of this
lecture, I'm going
to be skipping derivations.
Some of the derivations are
going to be in the notes.
So we have some operator.
And we want to know the time
dependence of the expectation
value of that operator.
And it's possible to
show that the expectation
value of the operator a is
given by the expectation
value of the computator
of a with the Hamiltonian
plus the expectation value
of the partial derivative
of the operator a.
So this is a general and useful
equation for the time dependent
of anything.
And it's derived
simply by taking the--
applying the chain rule
to this sort of thing.
So we have three terms.
And when you do that, you
end up getting this equation.
So this is just this
ordinary equation.
And anyway, so this
is what happens.
So we're going to have
some notation here.
We have a wave function.
And this is a
capital psi, so this
is a wave function,
a time dependent wave
function that satisfies the
time dependent shorter equation.
And we're going to replace
that by just something called
little t.
And we can write this thing psi
of x and t as the sum over n
Cn psi n of x.
And this becomes in a bracket
notation, becomes C Cn n.
So we have a complete ortho
normal set of functions.
And this thing is
normalized to one.
And now I'm going to introduce
this thing called the density
matrix.
This is a very useful quantum
mechanical quantity which
replaces the wave function.
It repackages everything we know
from the time dependent shorter
equation and the short in your
picture of a wave function.
It's equivalent.
It's just arranging
it in a different way.
And this different way
is extremely powerful,
because what it does is it gets
rid of a lot of complexity.
I mean, when you have the
time dependent wave functions,
you have this e to the minus i
E t over h-bar always kicking
around.
And we get rid of that
for most everything.
And it also enables us to
do really, really beautiful,
simple calculations of the
time dependence of expectation
values.
It's also a quantity
where, if you
have a whole bunch of different
molecules in the system,
each one of them has
a density matrix.
And those density matrices add.
And you have the density
matrix for an ensemble.
And so if the populations of
different levels are different,
the weights for each of the
levels, or each of the systems,
is taken care of.
But we don't worry about
coherences between particles
unless we create coherence
between particles.
So this is a really
powerful thing.
And it's unlike
the wave function,
it's observable, because
the diagonal elements
of this matrix are populations.
And the off diagonals elements,
which we call coherences,
are also observable.
And if you look at the Fourier
transform of the emission
from this system, it will
consist of several frequencies.
And those frequencies are
the off diagonal elements
with the amplitude, the relative
weights of those frequencies.
And so one can determine
everything in the density
matrix experimentally.
Now it's really--
it's still indirect
because you're making
experimental measurements.
But we think about this
thing in a way we don't
think about the wave function.
It's really important.
And this is the
gateway to almost all
of modern quantum mechanics
and statistical mechanics--
quantum statistical mechanics.
And so this is a really
important concept.
And we've protected
you from it until now.
And since this is the last
lecture both, in this course
and in my teaching of
this course forever,
I want to talk about
this gateway phenomena.
So what is this?
Well, we denote it by this,
this strange notation.
I mean, you're used to
this kind of notation where
we have the overlap
of bra with a ket
and or abroad with itself.
But this is different.
You know, this is a number
and this is a matrix.
And if we have a
two-level system,
then we can say that t is
equal to C1 of t plus C2 of t.
So state 1, state 2, and
we have time dependence.
Now those could be--
there's lots of stuff
that could be in here.
And this is going to be
a solution of the time
dependent shorter equation.
So since it's an
unfamiliar topic,
I'm going to spend more time
talking about the mechanics
than how you use that
to solve this problem.
But let's just look at it.
So we have for a
two-level level system,
we have-- it's a matrix
of 1, 1; a 1, 2; a 2, 1;
and a 2, 2 element.
And so we want the rho
1, 1 matrix on there.
And so it's going
to be a 1 here,
then we're going
to have a 1 here.
And then we have the C1, 1.
Plus C2, 2.
And then we have C1
star 1 plus C2 star 2.
And so have I got-- am
I doing it right now?
So the first thing we do is
we look at this inside part.
And we have C1, C1 star.
And we have 1, 1.
And we have C2, C2 star.
Now I'm getting in trouble,
because I want this to come out
to be only C1, C1 star.
So what am I doing wrong?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
both have C2 halves
the left hand and the right
hand half are both [INAUDIBLE]..
See, on the left side, you
have 1 on 1 [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT FIELD: So here--
And that's C2 C1
star, but that's 0.
And so anyway, I'm
not going to say more.
But this combination is
1, this combination is 0,
this combination is 0,
this combination is 1.
And we end up getting--
and then we end up
just getting this.
Rho 1, 2 is equal to C1 C2 star.
Rho 2, 1 is equal to C2 C1 star.
And rho 2, 2 is
equal to C2, C2 star.
So we have the elements
of this matrix.
And they are expressed in terms
of these mixing coefficients
for the states 1 and 2.
Now, if we look at this, we can
see that rho 1, 1 plus rho 2, 2
is equal to C1, C1
star plus C2, C2 star.
And that's the
normalization integral.
That's 1.
And we have 1, 1; 1, 2
is equal to 2, 1 star.
And so each rho is formation.
So the density matrix
is normalized to 1.
And it's Hermitian matrix.
And we can use all sorts of
tricks for Hermitian matrices.
Now we're interested in
the time dependence of rho.
And so we're going to use
this wonderful equation up
here in order to get the
time dependence of rho
because rho like a,
is Hermitian operator.
And so we could do that.
And so the time
dependence of rho
is going to be equal to the
time dependence of t, t.
Where we operating first here.
And then t time dependent.
And when we do this,
what we end up getting--
well, so we have a time
dependence of a wave function.
So we use the time
dependence shorter equation.
And we insert that.
And using the time dependence
shorter equation we have things
like--
so every time we take
the wave function--
the derivative of a function,
we get a Hamiltonian and so on.
And so what we can express this
time dependence of the density
matrix by just using the time--
inserting the time dependent
shorter equation repeatedly.
This is why I say this is
repackaging the Schrodinger
picture, repackaging
the wave function
and writing everything in
terms of these matrices.
So that's the first--
that's what happens here.
Sorry.
That's what happens here.
And then we write this
one, and we get plus 1
over minus i h-bar t, t H of t.
And we recognize that that is
just one over i h-bar times H
rho.
So the time dependence
of the density matrix
is given by this computator.
And the computators are
kind of neat because usually
what happens is these
two-level things have
very different
structures, and you
get rid of something you don't
want to deal with anymore.
And so now we actually
evaluate these things.
And we do a lot of algebra.
And we get these equations
of motion for the elements
of the density matrix.
And so we find the
time dependence
of the diagonal
element for state 1
is opposite that for state 2.
In other words,
population from state 1
is being transferred
into state 2.
And that is equal to
minus i over h-bar times
H 1, 2 rho 2, 1 minus
h 2, 1 rho 1, 2.
And we have rho 1,
2 time dependence
is equal to rho 2, 1
time dependent star.
And that comes out to be minus
i h-bar minus i over h-bar,
H 1, 1 minus H 2, 2 rho 1,
2 rho 2, 2 minus rho 1, 1
times H 1, 2.
This is very
interesting, but now we
have a couple
differential equations
and we can solve them.
But we want to do a trick
where we write the Hamiltonian
as a sum of two terms.
This is the time--
the independent part,
and this is the
time dependent part.
This is the part that
gives us trouble.
takes us into territory
that I haven't talked
about in time independent.
But it's still-- it's
perturbation theory.
This is supposed to
be something that
is different from and
usually smaller than H 0.
And so we do this.
So H 0, operating on any
function gives En times n.
And so we could
call these E zeroes,
but we don't need
to do that anymore.
And now we do a lot of algebra.
We discover that the time
dependence of the density
matrix is given by
minus i over h-bar times
H 1 of t times the
density matrix.
So this is very much like what
we did before, but now we have
that the time dependence
is entirely due to the time
independent Hamiltonian.
So everything
associated with H 0
is gone from this
equation of motion.
So now let's just be specific.
So here is a two-level
level system.
This is state 1.
This is state 2.
This difference is delta E.
And we're going to call
that h-bar omega 0.
So this is the
frequency difference
between levels 1 and 2.
H 0 is equal to minus h h-omega
over 2 h-bar omega over 2 0, 0.
We like that, right?
It's diagonal.
h1 is where all
the trouble comes.
And we're going to call that
h-bar times e x 1, 2 E0 cosine
omega t.
This is not an energy.
This is an electric field.
So this is the strength
of the perturbation.
And this is the dipole matrix
element between levels 1 and 2.
So we have a dipole moment times
an electric field multiplied
by h-bar.
So this quantity here, has
units of angular frequency.
And we call it omega 1,
which is the Rabi frequency.
It gets a special name
because Rabi was special.
And so we're going to be--
and this is-- expresses the
strength of the interaction.
So we have a molecular
antenna mu 1, 2.
And we have the external field.
And they're interacting
with each other.
And so this is the
strength of the badness,
except its goodness.
Because we want to
see transitions.
So now we do a little bit
of playing with notation
because there's just a lot
of stuff that's going on.
and we have to understand it.
So we're going to
call the state--
we're going to separate
the time dependent--
the time independent part of
the wave functions from the time
dependent.
And so state 1--
this is the full time
dependent wave function.
And it's going to be
minus i omega 0 t over 2.
in Other words, we should
have had zeros here--
times 1, right.
So this is the time
independent part,
and this is the
time dependent part.
And 2 is e to the minus i
omega 0 t over 2, 2 prime.
Notice these two guys
have the same sign.
This bothers me a lot.
But it's true, because we
have opposite signs here,
and we have a bra and a ket.
And they end up
having the same signs.
So that means that h
1 looks like this, 0,
0 omega 1 cosine omega t e
to the minus i omega 0 t.
And here we have omega 1 cosine
omega t e to the pi omega 0 t.
So this is a 2 by 2 matrix.
Diagonal elements are 0.
Off diagonal elements
are this omega.
The strength of the
interaction times the frequency
of the applied radiation
times the oscillating factor.
So now we go back
and we calculate
the equation of motion,
bringing in this h 1 term.
And so we have minus
i over h-bar h 1 rho.
And we get some complicated
equations of motions.
And I don't really
want to write them out,
because it takes a while,
and they're in your notes.
And I'm going to make the
crucial approximation,
the rotating wave approximation.
Notice we have a cosine omega t.
We can write that as e
to the i omega t plus e
to the minus i omega t.
And so basically
what we're doing
is we're going to do a trick.
We have the
Hamiltonian, and we're
going to go to a rotating
coordinate system.
And if we choose the rotational
coordinate the rotation
frequency right, we can almost
exactly cancel omega 0 terms.
And so we have two terms,
one rotating like this,
which is canceling or
trying to cancel omega 0,
and one rotating like this,
which is adding to omega 0.
And so what we end up getting
is a slowly oscillating term,
which we like, and a
rapidly oscillating term,
which we can throw away.
That's the approximation.
And this is commonly used.
And I can write this in
terms of transformations.
And although we think about
going to a rotating coordinate
system, for each
two-level system,
we can rotate at a
different frequency
to cancel or make nearly
canceling the off diagonal
elements.
So although the
molecule doesn't rotate
at different frequencies,
our transformation
attacks the coupling
between states individually.
And you can imply as
many rotating wave core
transformations as you want.
But we have a two-level system.
So we only have one.
And so we do this.
And we skip a lot of steps,
because it's complicated
and because we don't
have a lot of time.
We now have the time
dependence of the 1, 1 element.
And it's expressed as omega 1.
I've skipped a lot of steps.
But you can do those steps.
The important thing is what
we're going to see here.
We have e to the i omega
0 minus omega t rho 1, 2.
And we have a minus e
to the minus i omega
0 minus omega t times rho 2, 1.
And we have 2, 2 dot is
equal to minus rho 1, 1 dot.
And we have rho 1, 2 dot--
this is the important guy--
is equal to i omega 1 over
2 e to the minus i omega
0 minus omega t rho
1, 1 minus rho 2, 2.
So we have a whole bunch of
coupled differential equations,
but each of them have
these factors here where
you have omega 0 minus omega.
I've thrown away the
omega 0 plus omega terms.
And now it really
starts to look good,
because we can make these--
so when we make omega equal to
omega 0, well, this is just 1.
Everything is simple.
We're on resonance.
And so what we do is we create
another symbol, delta omega,
which is omega 0 minus omega.
So this is the oscillating
frequency applied.
This is the intrinsic level
spacing in the molecule.
And so we can now
write the solution
to this differential
equation for each
of the elements of
the density matrix.
And we're going to actually
define another symbol.
We going to have the
symbol omega sub e.
This is not the
vibrational frequency.
This is just a symbol that
is used a lot in literature,
and that it comes out to
be delta omega squared
plus omega 1 squared.
So in solving the
density matrix equation,
it turns out we care about
this extra frequency.
If delta omega is 0, well, then
there's nothing surprising.
Well, maybe e is just omega 1.
But this allows for there to
be an effect of the detuning.
So basically what you're doing
is when you go to the rotating
coordinate system, you have an
intrinsic frequency separation.
And so in the rotating
coordinate system,
you have two levels
that are different.
And there's a stark
effect between them.
And you diagonalize
this stark effect
using second order
perturbation theory or just
the diagonizing the matrix.
And so that gives rise
to this extra term here,
because you have the oscillation
frequency and the Rabi
frequency.
And anyway, when you
do the transformation,
you get these terms.
And so here is now the
solution in the rotating wave
approximation.
Rho 1, 1 is equal to 1 minus
omega 1 squared over omega
e squared sine squared
omega 0 t over 2.
We have rho 2, 2
is equal to just
omega 1 squared over
the e squared sine
squared omega e t over 2.
We have omega 1, 2--
rho 1, 2, which is equal to
something more complicated
looking.
Omega 1 over omega e
squared times i omega 0--
omega e, sorry, or 2 sine omega
e t minus delta omega sine
squared omega e t
over 2 times now
e to the minus i delta omega t.
It looks complicated.
And we get a similar
term for who 2, 1.
It's just equal to rho
1, 2 complex conjugate.
And so now what we see
is these populations
are oscillating not at--
It's a e, not a 0.
They're oscillating at a
slightly shifted frequency.
But they're oscillating
sinusoidally.
And we have an
amplitude term, which
is omega 1 over omega
e quantity squared.
Omega e is a little
bigger than omega 1.
So this is less than 1.
So it's just like the
situation in the absence
of this oscillating
field, that you just
get a slightly, slightly
shifted oscillation
frequency, and a slightly
reduced co-factor.
The coherence terms-- so these
are populations, populations
going back and forth
between 1 and 2
at a slightly shifted frequency.
And then we have this,
which looks horrible.
And now, for some more insights.
If we make omega 1 much
larger than delta omega--
in other words, the Rabi
frequency much larger
than the tuning, it might
as well not be detuned.
We get back the simple picture.
We get rho 1 is equal to
cosine squared omega 1 of t
over 2, et cetera.
So we have what we
call free precession.
Each of the elements
of the density--
the density matrix
is telling you
that the system is going
back and forth sinusoidally
or co-sinusoidally
cosine squared.
And what happens to
level 1 is the opposite
of what happens at level 2.
And everything is simple and
the system just oscillates.
Suppose we apply radiation
or delta t a short time.
And so what we're interested
in-- here is t equals 0.
This is time.
And this is t equals 0.
And before t equals
0, we do something.
We apply the radiation.
And we apply the radiation
for a time, which gives rise
to a certain flipping.
And so what we choose.
We have delta t is equal
to theta over omega 1,
or theta is equal to delta t
omega 1, the Rabi frequency.
And so if we choose a
flip angle, which we call
say a pi pulse, theta is a pi.
And what ends up happening is
that we transfer population
entirely from
level 1 to level 2.
When we do that, we get
no off diagonal elements
of the density matrix.
They are zero.
So if at t equals 0, we
have everything in level 1,
and we have applied this
0 pulse or a pi pulse,
we have no coherence.
If we have a pi over
2 pulse, well then,
we've equalized the
two-level populations,
and we created a
maximum coherence.
And this guy radiates.
So now we have an
oscillating dipole.
And it's broadcasting radiation.
And so all of the
two-level systems,
if you use a flip
angle of pi over 2,
you get a maximum
polarization, they're
radiating to my detector,
which is up there.
And I'm happy.
I detect their
resonance frequency.
And so the experiments work.
So we're pretty much done.
So I mean, what we
are doing is we're
creating a time
dependent dipole.
And that dipole radiates
something which we call--
if we have a sample
like this, that sample--
all of the molecules
in the sample
are contributing to the
radiation of this dipole.
But they all have slightly
different frequencies,
because the field that
polarized them wasn't uniform.
In a perfect
experiment it would be.
And so they have
different frequencies
and they get out of phase.
Or conservation of energy
as the two-level system
radiates from the
situation where
you have equal populations to
everybody in the lowest state,
there is a decay.
So there's decays that
causes the signal, which
we call free induction
decay, to dephase or decay.
But the important thing
is, you observe the signal
and it tells you
what you want to know
about the level system, the
two-level system, or the end
level system.
And it's a very powerful way of
understanding the interaction
of radiation with
matter, because it
focuses on near resonance.
And near resonance for
one two-level system
is not near resonance.
For another-- and so
you're picking out one,
and you get really good signals.
And you can actually do--
by chirping the pulse--
you can have one two-level
system, and a little bit later,
another two-level-level system.
They all radiate.
They all get polarized.
They all radiate at
their own frequency.
And you can detect the
signal in the time domain
and get everything you want
in a simple experiment.
This experiment has enabled
us to do spectroscopy
a million times faster
than was possible before.
A million is a big number.
And so I think it's important.
And I think that this
sort of theory is germane,
not just for high
resolution frequency domain
experiments, in
fact, it's basically
a time domain experiment.
You're detecting something
in the time domain,
and Fourier transferring
back to the frequency domain.
So there are ultra
fast experiments
where you create
polarizations and they--
it is what is modern
experimental physical
chemistry.
And the notes that
I will produce
will be far clearer than
these lectures, this lecture.
But it really is a gateway.
And I hope that some of you
will walk through that gateway.
And it's been a pleasure
for me lecturing to you
for the last time in 5.61.
I really enjoyed doing this.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank them.
Well, I got to take
the hydrogen atom.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.